comme le vélo ça s'oublie pas mais bon
les réglages ici là j'espère que je vais
pas perdre trop de balles aujourd'hui
remise en route difficile pour les
golfeurs amateurs d'autant qu'il faut
maintenant composer avec le respect des
gestes-barrières ouvert depuis le 11 mai
le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à repenser sa
façon de fonctionner on peut comme avons
joué à quatre personnes
on ne peut pas venir plus de 30 minutes
avant son heure de jeu qu'on doit
obligatoirement réserver et également on
doit donner un sens de circulation à ce
que le maximum de clients ne se croisent
pas du tout donc on a fermé
l'accueil des clients green fille au
niveau du pro shop et on a créé ce
stacker éphémère dans le grand hall qui
s'y prête parfaitement donc les gens
rentrent du parking dans un sens et puis
ils repartent
dans un autre pour aller sur le parcours
après ils peuvent
un parent visiter le pro shops ils ont
des besoins d'achats et aussi en a mis à
disposition une seule toilette
il ya certains endroits sur le site qui
sont complètement condamné tels que les
vestiaires qui ne rouvrons pas jusqu'à
ce qu'on a le droit sur le parcours il
est dorénavant interdit de toucher vos
drapeaux ou d'utiliser un râteau plus de
bancs ou des poubelles également les
gestes barrières on y pense
obligatoirement mais on y va pour le
plaisir on fait attention aussi à ces
gestes barrières heureusement qu'on est
un sport de plein air et qu'on n'est pas
un sport où on est bien sur l'autre donc
voilà on fait partie des privilégiés qui
peuvent reprendre leur pratique sportive
des premiers après au golf c'est rare
qu'on est con soit l'un sur l'autre sur
le parcours on arrose plutôt à droite à
gauche donc les gestes barrières on y
pense obligatoirement lt contrainte mais
pour la direction une satisfaction
néanmoins celle de freiner les pertes
financières durant les deux mois de
confinement ce sont 20 % de perte du
chiffre d'affaires qui ont été estimées
pour revoir les professionnels foulée ce
green il faudra en revanche attendre
encore un peu à l'open de france 2020
prévu en juillet ayant été annulé